alzi la mano chi sa che cos'è una smart
city
vedo che non ci sono molte molte mani
che si alzano per cui questo quarto
d'ora sarà sicuramente di grande utilità
in effetti non c'è ci sono tante
definizioni di smart city proprio perché
è perché questo perché la città è un
organismo molto complesso e anche la
città intelligente molto complessa
perché ha tante infrastrutture da
connettere fra di loro tanti servizi da
erogare e tanti soggetti che devono
collaborare insieme per rendere la città
sempre più vivibile e più fruibile ma
cosa pensano i cittadini della smart
city cosa hanno capito i cittadini della
zona city abbiamo fatto un po di
interviste per strada li abbiamo
raccolti in un video di cui vi faccio
vedere un pezzettino
beh è una falsità una città dove si è
possibile fare acquisti di servizi
utilizzi di beni tutto tramite app
tramite cellulare la smart city è una
città che ci deve mettere in connessione
conseguiti facile
smart city mi prendo un po alla
sprovvista organizzazione urbana
efficiente
non ne ho idea mi viene in mente non so
non lo so della città piena di
tecnologia di servizi il wifi pubblico
dove non devi pagare la fatto di
telefonino poter fare una serie di
attività che ci pensa allora smart city
e servizi appunto
che si possono utilizzare smartphone
fondamentalmente l'integrazione dei vari
servizi sia tecnologici rivolti anche al
sociale
ecco come vedete di tutto di più quindi
chi ha dato una risposta lo ha dato in
funzione soprattutto di quella che è il
suo modo di vivere la città e come si
aspetta che questo modo possa essere in
qualche modo migliorata allora qual è la
mia definizione di smart city con la
nostra definizione di smart city è una
città che mette al centro il cittadino e
rende l'utilizzo della città più
semplice più economico più sostenibile
allora proprio per per dare diciamo ai
cittadini ma anche agli amministratori
un modo per misurare quanto quanto
intelligente la propria città e chi è
scoprire chi ha fatto meglio e quindi
poter imparare da chi ha già fatto delle
delle esperienze
abbiamo inventato uno smart city index
quindi una classifica di tutte le città
italiane sul livello di intelligenza ds
città italiane ho raggiunto cioè i
servizi che sono effettivamente
disponibili nelle città e qual è il
risultato era come vedete il le città
sono 116 sono i 116 comuni capoluogo di
provincia che esistono in italia la
differenza fra le città è notevole la
prima e bologna che è considerata una
città molto vivibile ma dopo bologna ci
sono milano torino
ma c'è anche mantova che una città
piccola che si è reso ultimamente molto
smart all'ultimo posto abbiamo sanluri
immagino che pochissimi di voi sono
stati a sanluri che forse pochi sanno
anche che uno dei capoluoghi ufficiali
della sardegna dove noi abbiamo
riscontrato sono pochissimi innovazione
ed è un comune dove però c'è un sindaco
giovane molto brillante in via subito
chiamato per far vedere tutte le cose
che stava comunque facendo per rendere
smart la città e che sicuramente lo
faranno salire in classifica dove como
tra como e al quarantunesimo posto
quindi una posizione media diciamo senza
infamia e senza lode e poi vedremo
qualche dettaglio in più per capire
meglio come posizionata a como
allora come costruiamo noi lo smart city
index e quindi come diciamo cerchiamo di
classificare le città ci mettiamo dal
punto di vista di chi la città la usa
cioè cerchiamo di fare
facciamo i cittadini virtuali di tutti i
116 comuni capoluogo che cerchiamo di
muoverci nella città di studiare di
curarci di lavorare nella città e
cerchiamo di cerchiamo i modi semplici
per farlo qui andiamo a cercare se ci
sono dei servizi in rete su internet sul
telefono che ci aiutano a fare queste
cose nelle citta e la stessa cosa
facciamo
mettendoci dalla parte del turista che
cerca di capire che cosa c'è di
attrattiva nel nella città che cosa ci
possa trovare dove dove posso trovare da
mangiare ea dormire e come possono
acquistare in rete poi biglietti che mi
servono per per visitarla
quindi ci mettiamo proprio nell'ottica
di chi la città la usa e se troviamo
tanti servizi digitali vediamo tanti più
se non li troviamo tanti meno e così
viene fuori il ranking della città
allora mettiamoci la putizza del
cittadino abbiamo scelto un tema che è
quello della della mobilità allora cosa
vuol dire qual è la città che ha la
mobilità più più smart allora noi
risulta genova genova servita a torino
da milano ma anche arezzo e pochissimo
distante da genova quindi anche una
piccola città può avere tanti servizi
smart l'ultima e campobasso dove non
avevamo e abbiamo riscontrato pochissimo
innovazione e como chi posizionato un po
meglio della media era 41 41 nel
complessivo ed è 32esima diciamo quindi
sulla mobilità quindi sono un pochettino
più smart di quello che è su altri
ambiti c'è allora che cos'è che abbiamo
trovato a genova abbiamo trovato nelle
altre città che renderà la mobilità
smart abbiamo trovato per esempio delle
delle smart card dei trasporti pubblici
su cui è possibile caricare dei
biglietti e degli abbonamenti
abbiamo trovato che nei parcometri si
può pagare anche con col bancomat con la
carta di credito o addirittura come una
app
abbiamo scoperto che molto spesso è
possibile quando si è in giro per negozi
sia a pranzo con degli amici se in una
riunione e si è vicini alla scadenza del
parcheggio invece che scendere di corsa
a infilare le monete il biglietto
all'interno della macchina si va sulla
app e si prolunga banalmente di un'ora
il parcheggio
evitando così così di muoversi sono
città dove il tempo di arrivo dei mezzi
non c'è solo sulle paline che ormai sono
diffusissime città ma si trova anche sul
sul telefono per cui io se devo scendere
fra tre fermate prendere un altro mezzo
posso controllare se quel mezzo li è in
ritardo o sta arrivando per cui posso
decidere se affrettarmi per prenderlo
oppure se posso pigliare mela comode
sono città dove troviamo delle
informazioni molto focalizzate
all'utilizzo per esempio la tma milano
avvisa via twitter sullo stato di
funzionamento delle singole linee per
cui se io tutti i giorni prendo il tram
16 per andare a lavorare
voglio preferisco essere aggiornato su
qualunque mezzo pubblico che può avere
dei problemi ma su quel tram e lì per
cui mi avvisano quando si blocca se c'è
un percorso alternativo e mi avvisano
quando viene ripristinato il servizio
così sono in grado di organizzarmi
meglio nel mio nome dello strumento però
la comodità smart non è solo la ri
trasporto pubblico ma è soprattutto la
riduzione del trasporto privato quello
che si chiama la mobilità condivisa
ormai sempre in sempre più città
troviamo il car sharing il bike sharing
addirittura è stato introdotto in italia
e tra i primi in europa lo scooter
sharing cioè a milano e ci a roma c'è la
possibilità di poter scegliere un mezzo
qualche modo che non è mio ma è messo
messo in condivisione utilizzarlo per lo
spostamento per il tempo cui necessito
lasciarlo diciamo in giro per la città e
continuare a muoversi di conseguenza
perché le città puntano molto sulla
mobilità conti con condivisa perché ad
esempio uno studio è stato fatto a
milano indica che le automobili sono
utilizzate solamente 15 in media 15
minuti al giorno
ciò significa che stanno ferme
inutilizzati sostanzialmente inutili per
23 ore e 45 minuti tutti i giorni quindi
immaginate cosa vuol dire avere meno
auto nella città ma più utilizzate
magari in modo condiviso della più i
cittadini
queste sembrano discorsi utopici però in
realtà a milano in nove ann dopo nove
anni
in cui sono state introdotte piano piano
tutte queste forme alternative di
spostamento che danno la possibilità al
cittadino di scegliere i modi diversi a
cui spostarsi questo l'effetto che ci
sono 50 mila auto in meno cioè milan è
riuscita piano piano con questi mezzi a
togliere 50 mila macchine dal parco auto
che che circola che circola nella città
quindi gli effetti di queste politiche a
lungo andare si vedono ma addirittura ci
sono delle città che si sono reinventate
attraverso le tecnologie attraverso il
social network è questa una città
spagnola che si chiama un che è piccola
in realtà però a si era inventata ri
organizzata attraverso twitter non solo
il comune hanno accanto twitter perché
questo c'erano tanti comuni ma tutti i
dipendenti comunali hanno un account
twitter tutti i cittadini hanno un
account twitter fornito certificato dal
comune e il comune i cittadini dialogo
attraverso twitter i cittadini possono
segnalare la panchina rotta il lampione
guasto il verde mal curato il comune
mando una spara interviene e l'ha detto
fa la foto posta su twitter e
restituisce quindi sia al cittadino
della segnalato ma tutta la cittadinanza
il segnale diciamo che il che che
l'intervento è stato fatto questo ha
migliorato il la comunicazione tra
cittadini e comune perché i cittadini
sono più motivati a fare le segnalazioni
e il comune che i motivi è più motivato
ed è spinto ad intervenire nel più breve
tempo possibile
passiamo adesso al tema del turismo e
della cultura smart qual è la nostra
classifica cultura ma anche qui vedete
c'è tantissima differenza fra le fra le
città la prima e roma
allora roma è una città sicuramente
ritenuta problematica che i cittadini
romani anche visitatori tendono a
considerare tutt'altro che smart però
noi che analizziamo con questi parametri
molto schematici troviamo tanti problemi
tanti inefficienze ma anche anche
diverse eccellenze che che sicuramente
se fossero più conosciute
il cittadino userebbero di più questi
servizi e forse diciamo avrebbero una
percezione della della città di diversa
l'ultima in questo caso campobasso
scelto 22 casi in cui evidentemente a
campobasso la gente non si muove e non e
non ci sono turisti e como dove ecco
come è curioso perché è 56esima c'è una
performance peggiore della media quindi
alla 41esima sul generale e poi vedremo
perché perché su questo c'è una
riflessione da fare allora che cos'è che
ha diciamo roma di tanto particolare
allora roma un sistema online
multilingue per attirare i turisti da
fuori cioè si occupa soprattutto di
spiegare che cosa è possibile trovare a
roma dove si può dormire dove si può
alloggiare e l'apposita anche di
prenotare on line tutti i musei una
serie di musei e una serie di gallerie e
di monumenti online prima di arrivare
quindi tanti video i percorsi
personalizzati delle app che ti mostrano
che cosa puoi visitare in tornate nella
città cioè cura molto la tratti vita nei
confronti dei turisti dei turisti
esteri per esempio avrà app che consente
di saltare la fila in alcuni monumenti
nel colosseo c'è sempre una fila
gigantesca nei momenti in cui alla
biglietteria
però è anche in tempo reale io posso
tramite la per fare il biglietto mi
presenta l'ingresso e mi fanno passare
quindi che le tecnologie che consentono
di di di facilitare l'accesso ai
monumenti un'esperienza molto
interessante e molto futuribile questa
della realtà virtuale cioè il fori
romani ci sono due esperienze vengono
fatte nelle sere d'estate in cui in cui
ai visitatori vengono dati degli
occhialini e attraverso questi
occhialini si vede il foro ricostruito
la realtà virtuale com'era duemila anni
fa e c'è una voce del suo caso della
voce di piero angela che racconta che
cosa succedeva come venivano utilizzati
questi spazi che cosa succedeva duemila
anni fa i quali gli eventi storici divo
l'uccisione di cesare sono avvenuti in
questi in questi luoghi e quindi c'è la
possibilità di introdurre delle
tecnologie molto avanzate che consentono
di andare oltre le rovine pur bellissime
che ci sono che ci sono a roma il
prossimo passo è quello di abbiamo detto
cittadino turista e possono parte farvi
provare a fare il pacco perché anche il
tema delle merci e dei pacchetti che
girano nelle città è un tema che recita
sta molto a cuore molte città si stanno
muovendo nella cosiddetta smart
logistics cioè la logistica intelligente
per evitare che i camioncini girino
nelle città congestionando la e
ottimizzando la consegna delle merci
la chiudo su como
questa è la nostra visione
questa è la nostra bisogna di como su
tutte le aree su cui dicevamo
analizziamolo ma city index allora come
vedete quella la linea rosa il punteggio
che da diciamo a como il posizionamento
di como sud per ciascuna per ciascuna
area tematica non ci sono due eccellenze
che a como in cui il punteggio è
superiore della sanità digitale che
tipica un po di tutte le città lombarde
in cui per esempio qui possibile avere
tutti i dati sanitari clinici in rete è
possibile prenotare online a visita
sanitaria è possibile ricevere il
referto via e mail e e poi pagare molti
posti il ticket era online ma anche
sulle reti ambientali quindi sulla parte
che riguarda le acque le fognature il
verde pubblico i rifiuti
la performance di di como è superiore
alla media in italia vedi questi sono i
due punti di eccellenza i punti invece
un pochettino più problematici sono
questi che vedete con un riquadro in
rosso cioè le reti energetiche quindi
sul fronte della l'illuminazione
pubblica del l'efficienza energetica del
risparmio energetico ci sono città che
stanno puntando molto sulle energie
rinnovabili per cercare di rendere la
città un luogo dove si consuma meno
energia e quindi più sostenibile anche
sulla parte del government quindi i
servizi pubblici in rete molte città si
stanno spingendo sui certificati
anagrafici online sulle pratiche
edilizie on line sull'identità di
digitale quindi sicuramente su questo
como un po da lavorare la cosa
sorprendente questo e questo tassello
della cultura perché como è piena di
turisti è molto famosa nel mondo e
quindi stupì stupirebbe ritrovarla qui
in realtà è una caratteristica che noi
abbiamo riscontrato in molte città
d'arte italiane che in qualche modo si
accontentano dei turisti che hanno e si
accontentano quindi di mettere in rete
un po di informazioni per cercare di far
capire cosa si può vedere nella città
eccetera magari siti ben fatti però in
realtà molte città stanno scommettendo
molto molto di più su questo tema perché
dovete pensare che i turisti di domani
sono i giovani di oggi che si informano
condividono e sognano anche i posti dove
andare
su facebook su twitter su youtube allora
se una città non si presenta bene oggi
con tanti servizi in maniera molto ricca
su questi canali rischia che poi questi
giovani di oggi non diventeranno poi i
turisti di domani vi lascio quindi con
questo compito
grazie